the latest must-have accessory for
primary school children that is how I
saw smartphones been described the other
day on the prominent schools website and
it stops me in my tracks in the UK 77
percent of children now have smartphones
and nearly half of those are primary
school children yes Primary School
Education Minister Nick Gabe was now
called for us to follow France and ban
smartphones in schools and mr. Gabe when
it comes to primaries I could not agree
with you more in fact I would go a step
further and say this to parents stop
buying your young children smartphones
why on earth a 10 year old needs a
smartphone where hundreds of pounds is
simply beyond me so allow me to help you
and tell you this really clearly they
don't need one it's time for parents to
come together and agree not to buy their
young kids smartphones because this
really is pester power gonna step too
far I'm totally with you on this
Michelle I can't stand seeing young kids
with their heads and their phones all
day I understand that you know there's a
little bit of keep up the Joneses with
kids that's fine but it doesn't mean oh
man it doesn't need to extend the kids
in promising the worst thing would be
phones for me at the moment all these
kids is the boolean aspect whereas
before to be bullied you predominantly
had to be in the playground or somewhere
where the police could get you you can
now go in your own bedroom shut that
door and you can still be bullied
because somebody's popping up on the
screen and of the public and that for me
alone would negate the reason for me to
give it give my child a phone and say
right disappearin do what you want with
it it needs to be controlled because
it's destroying somebody's kids it
really is anyhow it's horrible
I thought I was going to completely
agree with you and so I heard you two
just now and I think I've changed my
mind because you sound like Luddite
having this debate now listen I feel
like it's one of those topics we need
loads of disclaimers so I don't think
primary school kids should have their
own smartphones I think it's terrible
the way social media is being used for
bullying and self-harm I think we really
need to monitor what children do on
technology generally but but when you
see kids on smartphones don't assume you
know what they're doing so for example
my daughter swipes my iPhone whenever
she can
she's seven I found that she's been
making directing cutting and editing her
own movie about she turned one of her
dolls into a very bought and she's
making this very book maybe at school
they learn how to make and edit their
own son because it's so creative
she's of coding workshops now when she
gets finished she'll be learning codes
she'll be trying to develop her own apps
I think it's cool sets math challenges
on the smart phone which I have an issue
with because it seems not all kids
parents can afford smart phones and I
don't think we should assume that all
kids you know I don't think their
schoolwork should be dependent on having
access to technology that's very
expensive but the reality is that it can
be a really useful educational tool and
kids don't just I think we always assume
that they're just stick to the gaming
and Instagram there's so much more
creative Matt and let me just be come in
I've got a teacher just listen to my
teacher Andrew Langlands there's a lot
of good educational tools out there you
can use for learning all the way through
up to sort of sick form who'd want to
get to university and and I think it's
really important part of education these
days so so I think a blanket band is
probably going to really struggle I'm
not saying it's okay for kids to be
texting in school I gave and the last
VIN I'm on this planet is a Luddite all
right seriously okay but there's a time
and a place for to be do okay to be
doing that stuff and you can't just let
it roam free with these with these
phones when they're doing all sorts of
stuff that the parents don't know but if
your kids watch you find it doesn't
that's fine have it for an hour I'll
probably give mine to the grandkids or
whatever do you not mean that's not a
problem but it's when they disappear and
doing their own stuff you know you can't
see what they're doing you can't monitor
you can't scroll back on what they've
been up to
that's when it's simple I mean with
common sense I am so happy because I
just occasionally can have regular
phones it's the smart phone that worries
you just I bought myself this this way
this old piece of kit purely because I
want people in a business context to be
able to call me like doing all manners
tablet majors callings fine so they can
have a regular phone you don't have a
problem with that so that will bring the
whole day get a parent because parents
will push back go I want
my kids have a phone for safety reasons
no problem if you really need it for a
safety reason then that they go the
problem there is and then we must have
other people in and I did totally agree
you know speaking as a parent and I
wonder if this is that the parenting
coming out here you could say well you
don't need a really nice bicycle you
should just have the most basic bicycle
what what do you want those trainers for
I can get them for $11.99 out of one of
those cheap shop or lastly what do you
need that particular item of clothing or
you know kids and one in four children
under the age of six as a smartphone I
mean completely nuts I mean I think that
that to coin a cliche the the genie is
so far out of the bottle and it's
learned behavior I mean children see
their parents completely addicted to
their smartphones they want what their
mummies and daddies have got but make
sure it's right if they need a phone
they don't necessarily need a smartphone
and let's just hear from a head teacher
who says it's actually a safety issue to
have children with phones parents feel
that it's really important but some of
our children who walk two or three miles
every day just to get to school
parents feel safer that their child has
a mobile phone some of the children can
be as young as eight and nine and if
they're walking to school parents want
mat.com for that security of knowing
that if their child needs them they can
get hold of them quite quickly
I interviewed a jockey who was on a pony
on a more from the age of four and her
father gave her just one of those and
just said ring me if you fall off or you
need a new shoe or something press the
green button twice I like the old days
where if you wanted to ring Michelle up
and make a date you had to speak to
Michelle's mom first and the landline in
2015 a study by the London School of
Economics looked at schools that banned
mobile phones from lessons the level of
improvement so what is the percentage
work done by the London School of
Economics schools that banned mobile
phones from lessons tested results
improved by what what's the matter with
this because I read the research as well
and there was no work no improvement
than there was as bad as if they too
many potatoes give me nothing what was I
don't remember outside probably
increases it because you can
3005 I know you and you're trying to
discredit my argument which means it's a
tiny percentage so I'm gonna go I'm
gonna clone fowl with the stats and say
that there was some kind of issue I'm
going for 40 percent 40 the number ISM
will show you two six is it that much it
supports are for an argument is it that
much of a destructive force well what I
would say to that is I would say that
children in the classrooms I know for a
fact right two things first of all yes
first of all they do get distracted by
telephone and second of all they do
leverage them as social social media
bullying tools often yes they can be
technology learning aids which is
fantastic so have them schools applied
in the classrooms for you to use your
point but ultimately you've got all
these parents but many parents that
can't afford smart phones that feel
pressured to buy smart phones because to
keep up with adjourns that the rest of
the kids in their classroom and I think
that is absolutely individual child in
Michelle I stay with Bri with Michelle
but also switch when a child has a
smartphone the data on the smartphone
the sites them they're visiting the
things they're looking at the messages
are sending are completely private to
that child to that user and we have seen
a girl a teenager called Molly Russell
who took her own life and now her
parents are having to take Instagram and
Facebook took court to reveal the data
and the site she's used you do not know
where your child is going if they have a
smartphone by all means give them a
phone an analog phone but a smart phone
you do not know I mean I'm not
advocating a aren't living like primary
school children their own smartphone to
use as they want I don't think there's
any substitute for good parenting for
monitoring what your child is doing
whether it's smartphone or not calm
I know well that's not true you can
monitor how your your children wander
you I wanted to I look at the history
she I have to logon for her she can't
buy things without me okay you know and
I think that's why she is not she
doesn't have her own no and I wouldn't
give her her own one until she's much
older wage I mean she
we've already had this with mommy when
am I gonna get my own y license 16 she
said 11 yeah science and all parents I
mean I think it's interesting that
you're the way you're saying this
Michelle because you're almost saying we
should legislate or do something to make
parents be more sensible when we've had
conversations like we've got other
things like for example employees who
won't make a stop to eat vegetarian food
you've been very much against the kind
of nanny state morning when I turned up
and I wanted my regular chocolate bar
and I was told I couldn't get one
because of a drive for healthy eating
you mean like that yeah I couldn't get
my salt because we're on a zero carbon
footprint no sachets with disposable
anyway think you're advocating banning
in classrooms I am I'm Claire I'm back
I'm advocates yeah I don't think kids
should be on smartphones in court I'm
saying don't assume that all smartphone
users are bad and destructive there's
loads of positive things a time a place
for this there's a time and place reason
so we'll agree on some of it some of it
I'm a Luddite anyway shut up cuz I've
got a phone called away